she's had a penis he would say Jesus
penis right now if Jesus is happy I
guess he had a penis but whatever how do
I get out thank thank you I was annoying
okay so there we here we are we stood
our entire health can you cut some
bruises I can live with that
but there was oh wait I missed something
in the box
no yes
wait it's sudden them I have I have the
bromine in the market now I need to get
the blood and I should be set all right
so I think we need to going back to the
laboratory right yeah
I think we need to go back to laboratory
I think not sure though yes this is I
actually remember the way now I think
huh I'm a genius actually I'm not a
genius
let's go this looks scary and dark I'm
scared why there was maybe these doors
open now yeah yes holy [ __ ] I'm scheming
apparently what is this this is where I
came from
oh it is it is yes nevermind
okay we have searched every room I think
we're done we can go don't worry I'm
leaving don't worry I know you're all
like you need some yes but I'm sorry I
just wanted to shake uh-huh then we can
walk in the pool no no no maybe drink
ale
okay that's enough of that
and go here
I think at least
I don't trust this place though a lot of
the wars it's dark I'm scared okay
I hate these doors they're so loud what
is this
spin around it's a spinner ooh I love
spinners okay so but hmm
what is this maybe you place this yeah
I'm a genius and then I should get the
blood first blood you mean you mean
what
okay all right I need the blood first
ah barrels ah I knew those barrels fault
but I thought for sure I was doing the
right thing with their table lucky might
pass air her barrels am i walking back
now I don't remember it feels like I'm
walking back yeah I'm walking back
follow the period P alright that's what
my dad said in case you're in trouble PD
come here son Shay to my life I want to
tell you something if you're ever in
trouble and you see period on the flower
just follow the period P you'll be fine
okay hi
right I really really really really
think this is how you should supposed to
do it I don't understand why is he too
sexy to do it ha I don't understand
maybe I can yeah I know
no I don't know yes I'm taking this with
you and you better not scare me again
frickin Iron Maiden I have a bear harm
and blood arm yeah blood I'm thinking
somewhere it's my arm we are going on
new a chairs oh it makes sweet noises so
yes - I'm a genius
yes who thought of that mmm-hmm-hmm you
thought I did it why you're not a genius
alright this but this here yeah
ass spinner ooh that's a tricky part
spinner ooh spinner ooh spinner -
spinner will spin a room yes I blood I
have blood yes
Oh letters if did nothing right I did it
Oh what uh-oh he wants me he wants me I
don't want him I don't want him out of
one in barrels I was aroused the battles
[ __ ] told me ok ok ok
this hi dear he wants me no problem no
problem oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh oh man oh man
oh man oh man please go I'm just doing
science here I'm just a scientist just
where is it
oh [ __ ] ice not a sexy-ass the other one
I have to what
what don't come back Oh didn't hear me
oh I saw his ass
I'd better than like that
I wish I could close the door he's
annoying all right I'll keep doing
science then what am i doing he's doing
science perfect now
what but now that's spit in it P you're
in oh wait I actually I don't know maybe
I need to add something I need to add
the bromine of course bro my there we go
but now we just have to make sure the
portal huzzah not for iPad your science
huzzah haha there you go there you go
we're not running soon
how's necessary ASSA wait didn't we
already follow the period yeah with it
alright good
uh-huh
so now we go in the middle
I think or where
I'm confused
yes yes yes all right let's finish this
freaking model ready go to the poor
little thing you lead ooh come on jump
now we can go here right yes yes yeah
sorry too excited uh-huh
hello ladies oh crap no free shows
apparently
what is this hey thump oh no never mind
I need Stefano seriously though where's
that ah it's not Stefano wait listen
no uh-uh-uh hello lady what have you
been I've looked everywhere for you
what are you doing on top of a shelf I
don't know ha ha no Stefan where did he
go oh [ __ ]
step on up Wow oh there is he's in a
really bad spot
it's the funnel okay carefully listen
carefully PD that monster is he's blind
you can see you just don't make a noise
okay okay so funny I'll try oh [ __ ]
stiff i dolly a lot of egg arrives I'm
sorry Stefani alone oh [ __ ] I get the
feeling he sees me
no no no it's called he doesn't see you
it's a problem is this me ah ah if I can
trust the follow this mistake ever
dorking at all darkness darkness i guess
i guess you can still sort of see me but
no I need a fine there is oh it's golden
golden ooh I love reading I am stefana
golden edition yes I am fancy I'm like
the pizza fella
yeah okay whatever you have a cousin
down there yeah I know it's fake fake
it's like it's like Gucci and [ __ ] you
know I'm go Chee and he's cussing you
get it not actually I don't but whatever
oh okay ah ok thanks wait PT I know I
know I know I just gotta put you down
there and then we're gonna read this I
believe easily I can't do this always
too much they were five siblings a long
time got born Duke blah blah blah
I grew up in the lavish home luxurious
uh-huh what's straw CK by a terrible is
this a hint maybe see speck birth did
alright cool cool story Brown good story
excellent sorry telling me accident I
was saying I'm sorry about the monster
early I really didn't think he did it
see you oh it's okay it's okay
but you have to binding me a new pair of
pants some potatoes I said all these
potatoes around there
Justine monster I understand ooh
which way oh Lola dog king kelana cough
cough Alana binky barman hula dueling
tough so this week's apparently every
time I do this I always do the wrong way
so okay
I'm gonna put you down here Stefano and
don't you dare go anywhere I've been
missing you a lot to follow there will
solve any scary moments I know pity I
know it's been scary for me too but I am
proud of you thank you sir
thank you ok I'll leave you here for now
just don't go anywhere just wanna loot
this place
what is this is this a puzzle fate what
fate fate what fate wha
fate okay fate penis you and wouldn't
that wouldn't make sense everyone has
penis in their fate if you think about
it
yes a-all right this comedy up the
South's roof whoa what that he's big
that's what she said hey anyway
let's go up just house after staff
speedy I told you already you need to
focus
I'm sorry you really are an idiot what
it ah why would you leave me here I
don't understand I'm confused I thought
uh there's got to be something with this
looks like pressure plates perhaps part
of a coal all right so it's possible
because we got boxes over here so I
guess we can use them but Stefano I'll
throw you over here no don't call me but
I you idiot
I'm sorry this is I need this box nine
eight seven six five four three
this looks like a tricky puzzle thank
you thank you thank you thank you thank
you thank you yeah eyeballs or is it dis
poo yeah it's probably just poop bread
yes okay so I guess we need these for
something maybe ah I need you Stefano
where are you
someone Oh get the way out turn off the
light bidet is coming at your belly
ah okay you're safe
no you know I was hug me I don't wanna
get one step out
ah rod better find the stairs it's after
you okay oh oh oh you'll be quiet not
really big white oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm so so so slow so slow
so sir
Oh Stefano see Polamalu smell alive he's
after me laughter me laughter me what do
i do whatever okay okay
Stefano be quiet every day ah you are an
idiot
you nearly got us killed again
I know Safari oh that was horrible
oh man what is he doing why does he want
from me I don't understand I don't know
either pity but I think he likes you
okay
yo ask me what I feel like staring at
the sky so Vendela telling Kurt Russell
homie this ain't real life I'll be
making good on my promises honesty's pop
it inside of it is missing but I realize
I could be better than I was lighter on
my seat cooking up the soul when we fire
up